this morning I'm sitting there saying  okay how much of this is real oh my God  Jon Stewart you make a lot of sense  these poor kids can you imagine being  stuck in a body and they're suicidal  these kids are killing themselves  they're suicidal are they suicidal  because they're being transgender are  they suicidal because you keep feeding  them this [ __ ] that they start  believing so then I said who was the  first transgender person in the history  of mankind was it in 600 BC was it  during Biblical times  was it in 200 A.D was it in 600 A.D I  must have been around a long time  because this transgender stuff's got to  be a few thousand years no  it's less than 100 years